What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity.
We have just hit 400 000 subscribers
Thank you so much for all your support!
I think it's time to see Emil in action.
One set match.
Me against Emil.
Let's go!
Good luck!
Alright, game on!
That was a pretty perfect return!
I was not expecting a short receive!
I went for the big backhand!
That was a good strawberry shot.
How did I miss that?
You got me there!
My reaction time was like 2 seconds slower than the shot
I had a chance there!
I set you up!
You can't get me with the edge!
I was expecting it!
Not even with the edge...
Lucky, lucky one!
Got you!
The winner!
That was a worthy winning shot!
Thanks!
Good match!
Alright, that was decent though.
It was!
Stay tuned for the big 500K match between me and Otto.
The stakes are high!
Subscribe to our channel here
And watch more videos there.
Until next time!